on t'a parlé de moi
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu as dit vous êtes le
diable
c'était vrai avoue qu'elle est bonne
tous les gangs de los angeles doivent
payer leurs taxes
à mon réveil cité à courre cambriole une
barque vol de l'argent à ta mère aucune
excuse ne va pas mettre sa dot au robot
vous avez l'air de deux monstres
tu vas aller en enfer ah ouais mais je
suis en paix avec ça tu te souviens de
la fois aussi marfil étroitesse
différents rien de rire linedata femmes
les enfants touchent à tour puissance et
terrorisé le troupeau c'est ça ma
fonction
dieu me permet de traverser les ténèbres
et de revenir à la lumière quand tu m'as
rencontre qu'est ce qui te plaît on
m'avait dit que tu étais un grand
méchant gangster tu taxe 43 donc de rue
différence a fait des milliers de gens
de la sous culture la plus violente de
los angeles
il manque de l'argent qui es tu je suis
l'avenir et toi le passé j'étais enfant
tu veux les racheter
crois pas qu'il veut du sang il veut
arracher le coeur le pass joindre à lui
ils s'enfuirent qu'est ce qui reste j'ai
sur moi de khalid 3 81 38 et à 25 à
chuck père dans le kop est un bien
commun qu'est ce que tu veux plus
j'assume
[Musique]
vous en prie les enfants du prêt à tout
sacrifier pour toi est un dur n'était
pas assez dur que ça
allez hop ta gueule il va faire sauter
la cervelle et je veux pas ça oui moi je
veux ça